they're the fastest growing Latino group
in the US and many immigrants fleeing at
Venezuela's economic collapse corruption
and socialist leadership are reportedly
giving a big boost to conservative
candidates across the world our next
guest has seen this firsthand disant
project founder daneli Martino who
immigrated from Venezuela himself and he
joins us now Daniel a lot of people you
know just even a few years ago so much
emphasis on you know how many people
were leaving Ukraine because of the war
but the biggest um diaspora the biggest
Refugee crisis in the world is Venezuela
almost 8 million people that's right you
know International organizations don't
like to talk about this but the largest
Refugee crisis in the world is not Syria
it's not Ukraine it's not even
Afghanistan it's actually Venezuela
right that's because Venezuelans are not
fleeing a war Venezuelans are fleeing
socialism and that's not a convenient
narrative to say and that's why we're
voting to center right parties in
general yeah so it's been interesting uh
they've left it's many of them are
coming here in fact they're the fastest
growing Latino population growing here
in the United States but they've gone to
Argentina they've gone to Ecuador
they've gone to Spain and in those
countries they're also affecting the
politics in fact um they say Cubans
warned us now we're warning you is sort
of their message when they come to New
countries correct yeah you know I I can
see it in my family who now lives a lot
of them in Spain I have people in Italy
I have friends in in Argentina you say
Colombia Peru everywhere
and the number two the the two top
issues for Venezuelans when they leave
is do you oppose as a politician in this
new country the Venezuelan regime and
two do you support free enterprise and
so that's why we're naturally aligned to
parties on the right yeah it m election
was you know obviously a bombshell
election a GameChanger for Venezuela or
or or so many people hope it will be um
but that was really a lot of Venezuelans
I mean obviously among many of the
Argentine population but a lot of
Venezuelans putting up Tik Tok accounts
social media in Argentina the right-wing
conservative social media ecosystem
became a big thing and they were posting
Venezuelan is posting Tik Tok videos
saying hey don't don't go down this path
we know what it's like could that happen
here do you think that could we could
see that kind of impact on our election
from Venezuelans well we will see it
especially over the next 10 years in
Florida because what you have to see is
that over half of the Venezuelan
population in the United States is
concentrated in Florida which is still a
swing state yeah and I think you know if
you if the estimates are are continuing
as they are the the Venezuelan American
voting age population will be the
largest the second largest immigrant
voting voting Block in Florida right
after Cubans within a few years yeah and
so they're going to have a huge
political impact here in the US they're
going to have a huge political impact in
Colombia where there are two and a half
million Venezuelans who are eventually
going to become Colombian citizens and
so just wait and and this will be much
bigger impact than the Cubans and
hopefully for the better to learn from
the experience of Venezuela that
socialism does not work yeah they know
it firsthand they're raising the flag
saying don't do it um it's really
interesting conversation thanks so much
Daniel thank you Rachel all right coming
up I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis